hey glamour it's miranda ko here i'm so
excited to answer your questions
and to walk you through my natural
glowing skin and makeup rooting so i'm
starting with a clean face
i've already cleansed my face in the
shower using our new
milky mushroom gentle cleanser so after
the cleanser i exfoliated my skin
using my favorite product our turmeric
brightening
and exfoliating mask which you can also
use as a scrub
next is our noni bright vitamin c serum
this serum has won multiple awards
because it is an incredible
brightening lightweight serum that
really actually looks beautiful
underneath makeup
my next step is turmeric glow
moisturizer this is
the cream deli cream of all moisturizers
is made with liposome technology
i use this product morning and night and
it's made a dramatic difference to my
skin
the next step is our noni glow face oil
which
i basically call liquid gold i apply
a few drops press it into my skin
it helps lock in all the other
ingredients that you've just applied to
your skin
my last step in my skincare prep is our
noni
radiant eye oil and you apply it around
the eyes
it's very soothing and cooling so now my
skin is ready
first thing i like to do is put a little
bit of concealer on
i like this it concealer bye bye under
eye
i put a little here and just put
in the areas next thing i like to use
is the rms beauty uncover-up cream
foundation
my friend rosemarie created this
and it's a creamy lightweight foundation
that is pretty good coverage
another thing that i what i like to do
is line my lips
this is a laura mercier pencil
in baby lips
it's very natural looking and it just
kind of
evens out my lips because i spot
lip balm i actually really love
blush so this is the blush i'm using
it's an rms beauty blush the tip that i
like to use with blush
is kind of go down from your um pupil
right down to the center on the apple of
your eye
i think it like adds that youthful
glow next i use a little brown pencil
from benefit
i love their brow products and i just
fill in a tiny bit
quite like a natural bushy brow
next step curling lashes
i just started using a new mascara
it's this by well people
it's in black it's expressionist
volumizing
mascara i have very sensitive eyes
so this one it's actually been
quite nice and then use our cora
luminizer
and actually apply it around
the areas that catch the light i love
this highlighter because it melts
right into your skin so
last step is powder this
is the flawless finish powder with
charlotte tilbury
and i just like to powder down the
center
so that i keep my glow on the outside
so there you have it that's my everyday
glowing skin look
[Music]
so here are my products my milky
mushroom cleanser which i
absolutely love it's a lightweight milky
cleanser my tumeric brightening an
exfoliating mask it preps the skin
so that your skin is glowing after that
i use our vitamin c serum and then
our newest product the turmeric glow
moisturizer which i'm obsessed with
and then the noni glow face oil which is
liquid gold
and the non-iradian eye oil and then
after that my skin is all prepped and
glowing
i use bye bye under eye concealer
and then the rms beauty
foundation here which gives a natural
beautiful finish
our rose quartz highlighter which gives
your skin
the most beautiful glow and the
charlotte tilbury powder
coming over here i use
the goof proof brow pencil from benefit
the well people mascara to natural
mascara that i've recently
started using and love the rms beauty
blush that actually we did
together as a collaboration it's called
heart
the kosa sport pulse
lip balm with the laura mercier
lip liner in baby lips tweezerman
tweezers
[Music]
my skin care philosophy is that healthy
skin is the most beautiful skin
when you give your skin the nutrients it
needs
it really has that opportunity to glow
and be as beautiful as it can be
my top three skin hacks of all time are
exfoliate dry body brush and
go organic the best beauty hack i learnt
is from
rosemary swift she taught me to curl my
lashes with a spoon
you kind of just go like that with the
spoon
my off-duty makeup look is pretty much
what i have on right now it's just a
little
a little bit of coverage with a little
light foundation concealer a little
blush
a little mascara and a natural lip my
biggest beauty indulgence would have to
be
the infrared sauna i actually bought it
for my husband
but i use it just as much as he does my
budget beauty thrill is
tweezers and i can actually tweeze my
eyebrows without looking like i can sit
there and just be like
my hot hair must-haves are rahul shampoo
e3 hair curler and josh lou's
hair ties i don't wear perfume i love to
wear
essential oils rose essential oil
geranium
neroli my quirkiest wellness ritual
is i drink 32 ounces of celery juice
every morning on an empty stomach the
best business advice that i give to
an aspiring beauty entrepreneur is
really listen to your gut if you have a
feeling and a passion
just make sure that you follow that and
know that it's gonna take hard work but
be dedicated
and don't give up thanks so much for
watching guys i'll see you next time